Oh what is going on YouTube now growing
up I have seen a lot of these
commercials
don't y'all remember that one video
growing up when you would see that one
all black I hold it like that AB can
baby saying this is baby negombo he has
no food or water degree two [ __ ]
every week this man will make you feel
like a piece of [ __ ] because you
couldn't donate five cents a day to save
a little baby somewhere across in
another country but I really got me to
think what about the kids that we didn't
say in our own country in the United
States I'm growing up I was one of those
ghetto kids that needed help but we
didn't really have any programs or
anybody's donating money to us so I
decided to go ahead and start my own
called Avis Zoe's ghetto Kids Foundation
check it out
you
now I know you've seen this before man
that is arms crossed asking you to dig
deep into your pockets to help out an
episode see these kids and eat your
health oftentimes inner-city user label
is bad ghetto
shut the [ __ ] up most of these kids they
aren't hoodlums they're just
misunderstood and broke yourself for
example look at Tommy scraggly ass but I
broke you seen yourself
[Applause]
children in this inner-city youth
program will be given opportunities like
they never had before
meet my flu Lu and affricate immigrated
hey I run that [ __ ] back my name my name
is Michael I can't read look at he's
trying to speak our language okay I
can't [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
first of all obviously you [ __ ] okay
you know they be so gentle kiss
foundation will be able to hear
OOP with the help of your donations will
be able to go ahead and support all
these degenerate asked is that a dog
goddamnit anyways huh you know what I'm
gonna [ __ ] about the kids anyway there's
always a nose kid it's been a rough last
day you know what [ __ ] you what Tommy oh
what the [ __ ] dude he's doing Tommy's my
little brother
Oh Tommy's lug that we got a little
different don't we have you know what is
actually a raisin [ __ ] heavy [ __ ] me
mean I got this [ __ ] was so bad you
wanna cross the line with stop playing
with that hair speeds are you rolling
[Music]
philosopher once said you could never
remove the ghetto from a child but
here's the baby so foundation you have
the opportunity to remove the chip whoo
yeah that's real funny doing you know
the camera you must be a dumb
[ __ ] won't you tell the care of
your name you're going to hey day where
you going to go camera guy where you
going man